[Musique]
en avril 2021 pour la première fois
depuis qu'homo sapiens et sur terre la
concentration de co2 dans l'air a
dépassé 400 20 parties par million la
dernière fois que l'atmosphère terrestre
avait connu autant de dioxyde de carbone
des requins mangeurs de baleines nageait
dans une mer dont le niveau était de 9
km est plus élevé que de nos jours et la
température était de 3 degrés
supérieures aux moyens d'aujourd'hui
c'était il ya environ 3 millions
d'années on en est vraiment pole mais
combien de co2 on peut encore maîtres
avant d'atteindre un réchauffement de
1,5 de grille
oui
les scientifiques ont estimé combien
tonnes d'équivalent co2 suffisent pour
faire grimper la température d'un
véhicule 5 degrés au dessus de celle qui
régnait avant la révolution industrielle
c'est la limite la plus ambitieuse que
la communauté internationale vis depuis
l'accord de paris au dessus de laquelle
les changements climatiques nous
exposerait à des conséquences graves
voire irréversibles
le nombre de tonnes de co2 qui ferait
grimper le thermomètre jusque là est
évalué à environ
2900 gigatonnes ça c'est notre budget
carbone c'est la limite maximale des
missions à ne pas dépasser
[Musique]
mais une tonne de co2 ça ressemble à
quoi au juste à la température moyenne
de la terre une tonne de co2 gazeux
remplirait un cube la taille d'une
petite maison
en empilant 1 millions de ces cubes on a
une méga tonnes on entend souvent parler
de mégatonnes quand on parle des
émissions à l'échelle du pays par
exemple le canada émet plus de 700
mégatonnes de co2 chaque année l'échelon
suivant c'est la giga tonnes
l'équivalent de 1000 mégatonnes ou un
milliard de tonnes si ce co2 était de la
meije on en aurait assez avec une
gigatonne pour ensevelir la ville de
québec sous un kilomètre de flocons en
débordant même un peu voir le fleuve si
on vient au budget total qui nous reste
on multiplie tout ça par 2009 ça c'est
presque assez pour ensevelir le québec
au grand complet sous un kilomètre de
pouding chômeur c'est la quantité
d'équivalent co2 nécessaires pour faire
grimper le mercure à 1,5 des cris
depuis la révolution industrielle
on a déjà émis près de 2500 gigatonnes
d'équivalent co2 principalement en
brûlant du pétrole du gaz naturel et du
charbon si on ne peut pas encore atteint
notre température limite c'est parce que
la terre absorbé une quantité
astronomique de co2 mais les capacités
d'absorption de la terre sont pas
infinies il nous resterait seulement 14
% environ de notre budget carbone au
rythme actuel ça laisse à peine plus de
dix heures pour se transformer en
civilisation carboneutre il reste à
savoir comment on répartit les efforts
entre les pays pour que ce soit
équitable c'est ce qui occupe les états
membres à chaque conférence mondiale sur
le climat et c'est un tout autre casse
tête